[Musique]
en tout cas ce que c'est un très bon
choix de restaurants pour un premier
rendez vous même si castro c'est une
très jolie rencontre
c'est vrai tu sais moi je trouves tu as
deux très belles couilles qui bling qui
brille tellement haut que tout le [ __ ]
et se reflètent dedans je ne pense moi
en tout cas je le pense oui
j'aime bien manger domaine est ce que tu
veux qu'on aille un petit peu marcher
dans la mouille à reculer [ __ ] on va y
aller vous prenez les chasses restaurant
voilà et c'est comme ça que je suis
devenu ingénieur
j'adore quand les gens vont jusqu'au
bout de leurs limites
j'adore paris c'est vraiment une ville
super même s'il ya beaucoup de
[ __ ] qui vole ça c'est pas bien
mais c'est parce que vous me donnez à
manger qu'ils restent ici
alors hein c'était une très très belle
sodomie pour moi et tu es vraiment une
fille de joie
et si tu me laisses ton numéro de
bouffeurs de que moi je t'appelle alors
excusez moi c'est un peu ça va être vite
j'ai besoin de ton homme j'ai dit
quelque chose qu'il fallait pas si c'est
ça je m'en fous je manque une tresse en
seulement voilà on n'a qu'à faire ça on
dit que tant qu elisabeth val jeu du
canal s'est passé comment elle m'a
retourné la pub
j'avais le gland qui battait fort fort
fort mais elle n'a pas voulu marcher sur
la bouche tu sais très bien ainsi toi /
spé des et raconte m comment dire
tiens avant est ce que tu veux boire du
1 comment tu appelles ça ça fils de [ __ ]
ah oui 13 buts
[Musique]
j'oublie au monde